Christ while all this Holy Spirit okay
welcome everybody you're here
huh yes okay Sam so um this is my sister
and she's the one I contacted you
earlier about she had some
questions uh so she has some questions
um we're born into obviously a Muslim
family like I told you earlier um and
there's been a lot of confusion it seems
like you look for answers and you're you
even growing up in the Masjid our imams
and shakes would teach us things that
were we find out now that they were
fabricated and um no one seems to know
what is fabricated what's not to me it
seems like the whole thing is everything
is but uh she just had some things like
I told you earlier where she was talking
to her friend and there were some uh
Hadith she would bring up and her friend
denied the Hadith she says she believes
in Quran only and she was trying to
insinuate my sister was out of Islam and
I said actually if she says that she's
out of Islam as well isn't that the case
Sam I can't I can't say that's right or
wrong because she may not be a Sunni
Muslim so to say that she's wrong
well it's like saying the she are wrong
it depends on whether you're Sunny
Muslim if you're sunl if you don't
believe in the Sunnah then you are out
of Islam from the Sunni perspective I
told you she was out of Islam through
the Sunni
perspective does not believe that is she
Sunni yes her friend
is she she's either ignorant or she's
lying because you cannot be a Sunni
Muslim and deny the Sunnah so she's
either ignorant or lying it's one of the
two I don't know her but I can tell you
that you cannot be a Sunni Muslim and
deny the Sunnah that's a lie right
that's what I try to explain to
um we were talking about different
topics honey if you feel comfortable
enough like unmute your mic and go ahead
and ask some questions yes because I'm
out of Islam fully I definitely am a
cair and I'm proud so you left Islam mam
their sister so she left Islam but now
what are you Islam then what what what
are you though uh I have no identity
right now I left about three weeks ago
live um but have been reading you know
um I actually have reading been reading
um The Gospel of John and Matthew and
I've read some to Hy and she agreed with
me that this sounds nothing like the
Quran you know exctly so you're still on
a journey so one thing guys you got to
remember I'm talking to the people
listening it's not enough that we see
Muslims leave Islam that's good from a
worldly perspective but if we believe
God is real Jesus is Lord he's alive and
there is life beyond on death then our
duty is to see people give their life to
the Lord Jesus Christ and fall in love
with him may we fall love with the Lord
so just keep that in mind so what's the
questions I'm here to
help Hi Sam there you
go um to be honest I have questions but
I'm also questioning everything sure um
so one of the questions I raised with my
friend earlier was uh why did he have
trade two black slaves for one white
slave and she said there were no slaves
he'd never own slaves yeah okay that
she's living in denial so I don't know
what to tell you so I mean she can deny
anything but that's not the truth the
fact is he owned slaves he sold slaves
and slavery is still part and parcel of
Islam in fact when they tell you that
Europeans enslave black folks who do you
think sold the slaves to the
Europeans it was the Arabs and I believe
black people as well it was the in
Africa was the Muslims specifically even
those who let's say were not Africans
but had conquered Africans settle in
Africa like you said Arab Muslims who
were selling blacks to the Europeans so
I don't know where does she get that
Muhammad did not own slaves or sell
slaves when the Hadith literature is
filled of references to the slaves of
Muhammad and the sound narrations like
Muslim and bukari talk about him selling
slaves buying slaves in fact according
to the sound tradition he
gave seven slaves for safia safia b h I
was telling her about that too yes yeah
so she said they're not slaves they're
merely people who uh wish to work for
him and do things he wants for free
because he's Prophet
Muhammad Psalm
27 Yahweh is my light and my Sal
Whom Shall I Fear you see repeatedly you
have nothing to fear if God is with you
and you trust in him Yahweh is the
strong defense of my life Whom Shall I
dread when evildoers come upon me to
devour My Flesh my adversaries of my
enemies they stumbled and fell the host
surround me en Camp against me my heart
will not fear the war arise against me
in this I trust one thing I've asked
from Yahweh that I shall see that I
might dwell in the house of Yahweh all
the days of my life that's all I want I
want to be with you I want to be with
you father I want to be with you Lord
Jesus I want to be with you Holy Spirit
the source of my joy and love and life
without you there is no life to behold
the beauty of Yahweh to see how
beautiful God is because he is Beauty
and he makes beauty and to acquire in
his Temple for the day of Calamity he
will conceive me in his shelter he'll
give you the strength to endure it in
the secret place of his tent he will
hide me he will lift me up on a rock and
Jesus says he is The Rock and now my
head will be lifted up above my enemies
around me when my enemies try to attack
me I will see them crumble before my
feet and I will offer in his tent
sacrifices the fruit of your lips and
praising him living for him with loud
shouts of Joy I will sing and I will
sing praises to Yahweh here oh Yahweh
way when I call with my voice on your
behalf my heart says seek my face you
see it my heart is aching for you that's
you you already had these qualities in
you because your heart was created to be
filled with the love that comes from the
true God and you were not happy with
this Lam because that's a false god so
my heart was crying out seek Him seek
yahweh's face your face oh Yahweh I
shall seek SE do not hide your face from
me do not turn your slave away in Anger
you have been my help do not abandon me
and do not forsake me oh god of my
salvation now watch this promise and
this relates to you ladies by the way
listen watch
here for my father and my mother have
forsaken me my parents will abandon me
will reject me because I've left Islam
they'll disown me but though they
forsake me y Yahweh you will take me up
you will make me your child and you'll
never abandon
me instruct me in your way oh Yahweh
teach me your ways lead me in a level
path because of my foes there are many
they hate me do not give me over to the
desire of my adversaries for false
Witnesses have risen against me and such
as breathe out violence I would have
despaired unless I had believed that I
would see the goodness of Yahweh I know
you good and you're real so I don't
despair in the land of the Living Hope
in Yahweh be strong and Let Your Heart
Take courage like Jesus said do not be
afraid believe in God believe also in me
hope in Yahweh can you sisters tell me
whether you can find anything like this
in the
Quran anything like this nothing Sam yes
uh she's muted herself and she was
messaging me
she's crying and I love this Psalm 23
I've read this to her before amen amen
she's doing what now she's uh in tears
she Hallelujah she's muted
herself this to her Psalm 23 that uh
yeah the Lord is my shepherd I shall not
want Hallelujah so you can see Jesus is
real he's alive he's more real than you
can imagine he's the truth and your
heart has been seeking him though you
didn't know it so now now you know what
to do read the Bible keep praying God is
already showing up he's already
answering you and he's showing you it's
Jesus it's not Muhammad it's not Allah
it's not Buddha it's not Buddhism but go
ahead ladies we're gonna wrap it up Sam
I think hone wants to say something what
after listening to this two hours and 16
minutes live
um it it breaks it down to Jesus loves
and Muhammad lusts you got it
say it again repeat again Jesus loves
and Muhammad lusts yep um I want to uh I
don't know the process because I know it
in Islam but what are the steps
to uh
follow your steps to give your life to
Jesus you mean yes okay boy you're G to
make me cry again damn what a night
you're really was just messaging me that
will how will I feel if she uh accepts
Jesus tonight I said I'm always here for
you and I love and respect Jesus and I
told her be bold in your faith it's not
enough you're gonna have to take that
Journey eventually but no pressure on
you I'm reading I'm reading every day
Sam okay well here number one what you
two ladies need to do you're going to
need to go to a solid church right now
you don't need to worry about
yeah this a big issue but you got to
find a solid
church where you can attend regularly
and understand the
word and then we'll talk maybe in Skype
where that is because I don't want to
give out your location we'll talk about
it in Skype but the first step for
anyone who wants to give their life to
the Lord is confession and water baptism
so that means that's why you have to be
intentional of going and getting
baptized in water in the name of the
father spirit because your confession
and that act of baptism is what unites
you to Christ makes you one with him in
the spirit but the first step if you
want to renounce Islam right here and
you want to acknowledge Christ that
Christ I'm ready to give my life to you
what you have to do is confess with your
mouth verbally because that's let me
show it to you there's a lot you're
going to learn about Christianity like I
said the Lord says you're going to go
through trials but I'm with you so but
here's what we're told here it
is Romans I literally told her today
when she was talking to me about
Muhammad she's constantly messaging me
or calling me to tell me more things and
so I said if I can talk to Sam shamon
you you'll get me and she called me a
few minutes later and I was like no way
yeah it's not me sister it's the spirit
working through me so God heard your
cries again I notice again I want you to
see what you just said you you basically
said and God heard you so you're going
to make me cry again you basically said
said and God heard you God heard you if
you
get me to talk to Sam Shimon you'll get
me so Jesus said oh yeah that's what's
going to take for me to have your
heart I told you you're gonna make me
cry yeah let me speak while you go
everyone in the chat Sam I took a chance
and I called him on Skype and he didn't
pick up and then he called right back
and I explained to him my sister wants
to talk to you I've been sending her
videos for months now I bombard this
poor girl to open her mind she has
always had the most loving Spirit they
tried to fill her with hate in her
Islamic school she went to and she never
was hateful like them and she always had
this beautiful spirit in her and I've
been bombarding her and today she said
okay she loved Sam's videos and she she
was like wow he's so smart and he's so
you know just the way you know about
everything and she said if you can get
him to talk to me and I said okay
because I'm very angry full of hate for
Muhammad so I called him and he P called
me back and he said okay set up a time
and this is miraculous I cannot believe
this is happening but I'm so proud a
miracle no let me tell you why it's
happening this is not me I'm not trying
to be humble Jesus is so real
and he's alive that when he
heard what she said he goes is that
what's going to take for you to give
your heart to me Sam's going to be on it
it was the Lord not me it was the Lord
in fact if I tell you I wanted to leave
I was going to leave the house because I
wanted to go hiking God said no you're
not hiking today there's something more
important there's
this there's this young
lady who
said that if she reaches you and speaks
to you she'll be ready to give her heart
to me and now I'm going to honor her
request and you're going to speak to her
that was Jesus again I'm letting you
know that was Jesus when you contact me
I was resting to go hiking because I try
to work out the Lord says no there's
other plans today Sam no hiking that's
not
important this is true Sam
soon as you know if she tells you if
today and she was at Chuck-E-Cheese with
her son and she was like really today
and I said yeah you want to and so we
set it up and here we are
um yes Sam my son has never this quiet
ask her we talk all the time he's never
this quiet he's letting Jesus speak to
me yeah because I surprised he hasn't
been the one you understand what that
means Mariam Jesus is more real than can
imagine he's doing a miracle so that he
can show you look you're next lady I'm
waiting yeah because even the name you
chose you're named after the greatest
woman the greatest creature that God
created Mary the Mother of Our Lord her
name is maram she carried the Creator
and his fullness in her belly to become
flesh from her to save us so the Lord
sees that you have called yourself after
his mother he sees you called yourself
after his mother and he's not going to
let you off that easy because he wants
your heart because he created you to be
in love with him but now for your sister
here's the first step and then Lord
willing I want to contact you guys on
Skype I'll give her my number we'll take
it but the first step the first step
is here it is that if you confess with
your mouth here it is Romans
109-113 Jesus is Lord see with your
mouth means it's got to be verbal it's
got to be Audible and this was done in
front of witnesses
and believe in your heart that God
raised him from the dead that he didn't
remain dead he rose again he's alive
will
return you will be saved you will be
saved when he comes he'll come for you
to save you he won't judge you for with
the heart a person believes leading to
righteousness and with the mouth he
confesses leading to Salvation see the
mouth for the scripture says whoever
believes on him will not be put to shame
he will never shame you humiliate you
disgrace you Christians may do that CU
we're we're sick puppies he won't for
There's no distinction between Jew and
Greek He Loves All Nations he doesn't
care about their ethnicity or gender he
loves all genders male and female
there's only two for the same Lord is
Lord of all abounding in riches for all
who call on him forever calls on the
name of the Lord will be saved see he's
saying if you call on me you'll be saved
and now that's part of it but here's the
part that goes with it which is what you
do now God sees your heart he knows your
desire that you you want to do it so the
Lord has mercy and he's patient with you
now watch the other part Galatians
32629 Galatians 32629 for you are all
Sons Sons means Sons and Daughters of
God how through faith in Christ Jesus
here's this the element for all who were
baptized that's a water baptism into
Christ have clothed yourself with Christ
and when you've done that look at his
promise there's neither Jew nor Greek
God doesn't love Jews more than the
Greeks meaning Gentiles
there's neither slave nor free man God
doesn't dishonor slaves and honor free
men there is no male and female God
doesn't love males more than females for
you are all one in Christ Jesus he loves
his daughters as much as he loves his
sons and if you belong to Christ in
Abraham's seed heirs according to the
promise so it is confession from your
heart and baptism so if you really are
serious and you want to confess you can
confess now that's up up to you I don't
want pressure I don't want you to do
something it's got to be from your heart
you got to want to do it and if not
that's okay too in my heart I've always
been following Jesus I'm just ready to
say it out loud all right okay now that
means Mariam you gota keep on mute hany
you're G to repeat after me but first
what I want you to do is renounce
Muhammad so I want you to repeat this
after me you
ready ready I renounce Allah
Islam can you say that again I renounce
all of Islam I renounce all of Islam I
renounce Muhammad as a prophet I
renounce Muhammad as a prophet and I
renounce the Quran and I renounce the
Quran good now from your
heart get ready from your heart It's
gotta be from your heart say from the
heart I
confess I confess Jesus is Lord Jesus is
Lord yes he is who died on the cross
who died on the cross rose again on the
third day rose again on the third day
send it to
Heaven send it to Heaven sits at the
right hand of God the Father sits at the
right hand of the of God the Father I
confess I confess Jesus is alive Jesus
is Alive and will return to the Earth
and will return to the Earth to judge
the living and the dead to judge the
living and the dead Lord
Jesus Lord Jesus I give you my heart I
give you my heart my soul my soul my
spirit my spirit my body my body my
everything my everything I trust in you
I trust in you and I love you because
you love me and I love you because you
love me never let me go never let me go
it's in your name Jesus it's in your
name Jesus that I ask these things that
I ask these things amen amen that begins
your journey